I walked up to him I was like dude why
aren't we doing another movie can we I'm
I'm gonna call Jim today Arnold
Schwarzenegger is
a man whose life has been defined by
that genre allowing me to be there up
beside him was a moment and Melanie
miss Kiss
you know it's so funny you said to me
you know I don't know what to say and
I'm afraid I'm not going to say the
right thing but you are incredible that
was Exquisite exquisitely written
beautiful thank you so much you're such
an icon thank you so much how do you
describe the feeling of today you know
what it's it's actually been fun I mean
life is this part of life is fun this
isn't I'm not overly emotional this felt
very celebratory I thought Melanie's
speech about me was very moving but it
just shows that we love each other I am
so happy to be here today
to honor and celebrate one of the most
extraordinary women that I've ever known
my friend Jamie Lee Curtis I may cry
sorry Arnold couldn't have been sweeter
I'm a good friend of Jamie Lee Curtis
and I had the pleasure of working with
her in True Lies
and uh
she was the most extraordinary actress
that I've ever worked with
I mean this is a serious serious player
that can kick some serious ass just been
celebratory so I'm I'm I'm gonna take
this as a win in a hard life where
people are struggling and I've struggled
a lot in my life and in this moment so
far today has been a beautiful day I
have to say Arnold was a surprise for us
we didn't know he was going to be here
and I'm a True Lies Stan what type of
memories did that bring back well it
made me want to do another one with him
I came by your office today
I was in the area and I thought that you
made one day of lunch
Henry I'm I'm gonna call Jim today you
know you couldn't you couldn't watch
your lives for years you could not get a
copy of it and it's like finally on Hulu
and I'm obsessed I want to know if this
is true I heard the story that the first
day of Halloween you left and you were
like I think I'm gonna get fired from
this no I didn't think I was I thought I
did a great job I really felt very
connected to Lori and and then I got
home and then the phone rang and my
roommate Tina Cassidy at the time said
Jamie John Carpenter is on the phone now
normally
when a director calls you at home after
a full day of work your first day of
work I've heard of those stories where
people have been fired and you
you know you know that's a possibility
and I was that walk to the phone was
long and then I remember it felt like it
was a thousand pounds heavy and I
remember putting up to my ear and going
like
hello and this is what John Carpenter
said to me that day
hey darling because he's that guy hey
darling I just want to let you know
how great today was and how excited I am
to be working with you on this and
I just wanted to let you know that that
was a great day of work because it was
the character work we were doing it was
Lori with her friends was Lori
babysitting the little boy walking down
the street singing the song of longing
for love and it was the character work
that we were doing and I think he just
saw that character
you know kind of come alive that day as
I felt and I just that moment and by the
way is the only director in my entire
career who has ever called
after a first day of work to say that
they were happy and that it was good
[Music]